if you've ever taken a vacation to one
of the many islands of greece then
you'll know why the likes of crete
lesbos and corfu are famous for their
beautiful beaches but there is one beach
in particular tucked away in a corner of
an unknown island that you might think
twice about visiting why well the same
reasons that this place happens to be a
site of great interest for the scp
foundation also tend to drive tourists
away today we're talking about scp-2217
the strange anomalous happenings that
have taken place there and how it links
to none other than one of the
foundation's most infamous groups of
interest at first glance
scp-2217 is an ordinary uninteresting
beach just another pretty picturesque
view on a greek island it looks like the
kind of place that would be perfect for
a romantic walk at sunset but we
wouldn't recommend it although you
wouldn't know just from looking at it
the sand that this beach is composed of
has some pretty peculiar properties it
contains the ordinary non-anomalous
things you'd find in sand anywhere else
in the world normal levels of silicates
and calcium compounds but the beach also
possesses a high concentration of
cationic metallic particles these tiny
almost microscopic metal fragments
somehow hold an electrical charge
despite being grounded so it's a beach
with partially metal sand nothing too
unusual there right wrong the metallic
particles within the sand seem to have a
profound effect on the natural
environment to round
scp-2217 for one the metal content of
the beach influences the weather
increasing the number of lightning
strikes that hit the shore the metals
draw the static electricity in the
atmosphere this along with other weather
conditions and natural processes that
take place at scp-2217
also have a far more obvious anomalous
effect lightning rain even fish washed
up and decaying on the shoreline have
all caused various artificial structures
and devices to rise from the beach which
have all been designated by the
foundation as scp-2217-1
among the creations found on the beach
in the wake of lightning strikes are a
number of different forms of machinery
these have included simple clocks and
other timepieces to complicated
automatons these machines have no
notable anomalous properties as far as
the scp foundation is found apart from
the way they came to be and they are
otherwise fully functional also
discovered at
scp-2217 was jewelry seeming to be made
of discarded waste that washed up on the
beach and the tide resembling bears and
other recurring motifs of a certain
religion these articles of jewelry have
been made using everything from old
light bulbs to holes of ships and even
fish and animal bones most notably
however was the appearance of a city or
rather a model of a city that was
created at the beach and was then
referred to as scp-2217
there is a cliff located on
scp-2217 and if one is to swim through
an underwater entrance they will find
themselves inside a grotto there somehow
carved by tidal erosion of the rock is a
recreation of an ancient greek city
although the geographical features of
the model seem to resemble an area near
lake bakal in southern siberia the city
bears more of the same religious
iconography to the jewelry that can
often be found on the beach but which
religion the same one that considers
scp-2217 to be a site of holy importance
the church of the broken god now some
important context to make note of for
any who are unaware the church of the
broken god is a religious organization
that the scp foundation has had a number
of encounters with over the years
members of the church share in their
belief that biological flesh-based life
is inherently wrong an abomination even
evil this religion worships
mechanization the process of making
something or someone more mechanical in
nature according to the beliefs of the
church there were two gods yaddabath and
meccan who created humanity together
yaddabath was a god of flesh and animal
instinct granting human bodies meanwhile
the god of machine and intellect mccain
blessed man with the power of free
thought as humankind developed its
civilizations by building machines
yaldabath became enraged that they were
ignoring the instincts she had bestowed
upon them she endeavored to destroy the
creations of man in an attempt to revert
them to the animal she had intended them
to be as the church's legend goes mccain
acted as humanity's savior and tried
desperately to stop yaldaba the god of
machine shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow god fragments of
meccan rain down on planet earth now the
church of the broken god believes it is
their duty to recover these missing
parts and put their savior back together
within the religion of the church of the
broken god there exists a splinter
faction that broke away from the main
church this group referred to as the
broken church are the ones that regard
scp-2217
so highly considering it to be a holy
site according to a piece of scripture
from their religion the broken church
believes the beach to be mccain's
workshop the book of rites describes the
legend of a boy looking out at the ocean
with his family and seeing fire rain
down on the shore sent from god or
meccan to the church mccain apparently
proclaimed that the beach was his
workshop where he made many wonders the
lightning is my hammer the earth my
anvil the sun my ingot mccain explained
to the boy so the legend goes and
invited the child into his workshop the
broken god brought his hammer down on
the boy but instead of killing him
marked him as the first of the religion
the broken church now follows in 2014
the scp foundation recorded an
earthquake taking place at scp-2217
with the grotto containing the model of
the ancient greek city at the epicenter
sending a robotic probe into the grotto
to assess the damage only to find a
surprising change that had occurred for
the first time there were a number of
humanoid figures seen within scp-2217-a1
and worse still they were under attack
within the model city what appeared to
be a number of individuals infected with
scp-610 were ransacking buildings
devouring and infecting the other
humanoid figures also known as the flesh
that hates
scp-610 is a contagious skin disease it
is usually transmitted by direct skin to
skin contact and anyone that is infected
with it suffers a horrific mutation that
transforms them into fleshy inhuman
monstrosities
these infected creatures will attack and
infect anyone nearby that isn't also
carrying
scp-610 interestingly the disease was
first discovered to be localized to a
small area in siberia not dissimilar to
the area that the
scp-2217-a1 model resembled according to
some sources scp-610
is the flesh described by those
following the religion of sarkicism a
cult that worships flesh and disease
sarkicism is a sect that directly
opposes and antagonizes the machine
revering church of the broken god three
years after the earthquake members of
the broken church staged an attack on
the beach hoping to reclaim
scp-2217 for their religion at the time
the scp foundation had closed off the
area to the public under the cover story
that
scp-2217 was private property they had
been hoping to predict the lightning
strikes that caused the anomalous
devices to form on the beach instead the
foundation had to repel the broken
church's attackers any way they could
however as the lightning began to strike
again members of foundation personnel
that found themselves caught in it
seemed to change sides all stating that
god needs to be reassembled only a year
later in 2018 another group of broken
church zealots stormed the beach and the
foundation outpost located there this
time the church seemed to have gained
further reinforcements specifically
members of other groups of interest in
particular some belonging to the church
of maxwellism and the cogwork orthodox
church both of which were also splinter
groups of the church of the broken god
the cogwork orthodox church arose during
the industrial revolution believing that
adding mechanical parts to their own
bodies offered greater understanding of
mechane and brought them closer to their
god maxwellism in a similar vein had
another interpretation of the church's
core beliefs favoring smaller more
advanced cybernetic implants the church
of maxwellism sought to modify their
brains to become a collective
consciousness and commune with meccan
despite a lot of pre-existing animosity
between the three core splinter groups
of the church they were able to
successfully capture scp-2217
the three factions sent a video message
to the foundation proclaiming the
importance of their mission oh
disassemblers who call themselves a
foundation what are you a foundation for
if you are a foundation for life then
you will let us keep this land for the
flesh is coming and only we can stop it
we need to bring our god back together
immediately or else you will all perish
and now it is time if you are a
foundation for life you will not let
this happen you will let us defeat the
flesh several more messages were sent to
the foundation demanding the release of
various scps with connection to the
broken god you see there could
potentially be hundreds of pieces needed
to rebuild meccan so he can lead the
church to glory and defeat yaldabaoth a
number of these pieces happen to be
catalogued as cps and the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
these include
scp-882 or his broken heart to the
church
scp-271 his broken gift
scp-813 his broken eyes
scp-1139 his broken tongue
scp-635 his broken mind and finally his
broken blood which refers to scp 217
with the beach under the control of the
church of the broken god any foundation
personnel left alive on
scp-2217 defected and joined the church
in order to retake the beach and
re-establish containment the foundation
was forced to do something that they
only do in the most dire of
circumstances
ask for help together with the horizon
initiative and global occult coalition
the scp foundation established what it
called the triumvirate a joint task
force in 2019 another earthquake was
detected this time in lake baikal
siberia where scp-610 was contained not
long after infected individuals were
reported to be attacking foundation
forces in the area causing heavy
casualties but then an unlikely event
took place members of the church of the
broken god appeared their bodies
augmented with machinery these zealots
that had fought the foundation for
control of
scp-2217 were now coming to its aid to
repel
scp-610 according to them god or rather
mccain had told them to come to assist
the foundation using a large-scale
electrical discharge instances of the
scp-610 contagion were eradicated but
this discharge seemed to have originated
from the same island where
scp-2217 was found
following this incident robert romero
the leader of the broken church sent a
video message to the leaders of the
triumvirate including the o5 council the
director of the global code coalition
and the horizon initiatives tribunal in
his message boomero stated it's not too
late you know this is our world as well
we both want the flesh to end and we can
help you we can help each other come to
the anvil we will talk and we can save
this world the church of the broken god
its splinter groups uniting to take
scp-2217 for their religion were now
extending an olive branch to the
foundation and its allies all in the
name of protecting the world shortly
after the foundation global cult
coalition and horizon initiative began
working collaboratively with the church
of the broken god to prepare for an
xk-class scenario retaking control of
the scp-2217
beach for now the foundation intends to
revoke this current arrangement after
the dangerous scenario has been averted
but perhaps mccain's workshop will
provide vital in reassembling the broken
god and saving humanity should yaldabach
ever return to exact her terrible
revenge now go check out scp-001 the
broken god or boro cycle and
scp-5094 miss j's whiz kid schoolhouse
for more technological scps